Xin chào mừng bạn quay trở lại kênh tin
học Đỗ Bảo Nam vào lúc video ngày hôm
nay đô Bảo Nam Block sẽ chia sẻ với bạn
một số thao tác cơ bản thương dung trong
Word
khuyên và nút mình đăng dung chính là út
2021 phiên bản này có giao diện giống
hai với bản Microsoft 365 ở thời điểm
hiện tại
và so với các phiên bản cũ hơn như 2019
2016 2013 thì word 2021 Nhìn hơi khác
một chút so với các phiên bản kia
Tuy nhiên các thao tác cơ bản chốt thi ở
các phiên bản Word khác nhau đều tương
tự nhau
và ngay bây giờ mình sẽ đi vào một số
thao tác cơ bản thường dùng trong Word
hao tác thứ nhất chính là nhóm thao tác
đóng mở và lưu file which Ví dụ như
Facebook mà bạn đang nhìn thấy trên màn
hình
ở đây đóng vai út bạn đưa chuột vào dấu
ích ở góc trên cùng bên phải Và bạn chỉ
cần nhấp Chú sáng vào đây để đóng vai
một
hoặc Mạnh có thể khiến tàu phím tắt đó
làm phim am + F4 trên bàn phím
như vậy mình đã đóng Facebook vừa thôi
tiếp theo mình sẽ chia sẻ xanh thao tác
đó là mở một file mới
ví dụ nếu bạn đang ở ngoài desktop bạn
có thể click đúp vào vai ai cần Vuốt để
mở file which
xóm bạn chọn đó anh chắc coment để mở
một phút mới không có nội dung như vậy
mình là tạo một tay ôm mới
và để tắt cái bút Này nếu như bạn không
lưu và chỉ cần kích vào cái giúp ích
Hoặc bạn có lời đau buốt từ menu start
bằng cách clip cháy vào cái step
sao cho icloud ở menu that I em và bạn
vẫn chọn cho anh cái của mình để tạo một
Facebook trắng
da sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ gọi nhanh một vài
nội dung Chào mừng bạn
[âm nhạc]
mà bây giờ mình sẽ thực hiện theo khác
Hương thấy hốt này cách nhanh nhất bạn
hãy dùng phím tắt đó lại bạn dùng tổ hợp
phím là control + s Trên bàn phím
sau đó bạn chọn thư mục profile
ví dụ đây mình sẽ được ra desktop
và bạn đặt tên file Ví dụ như chào mừng
và bạn nhấp vào xếp để lưu Facebook này
như vậy là xong
ngoài cách này bạn cũng có thể kích hoạt
file trên menu
sau đó chọn xếp
Hoặc bạn có thể nhấp vào sếp em để lưu
thành một pháp khác à Ừ thôi Bây giờ
mình sẽ quay trở lại
Ngoài ra để mở một forward đã có ở trong
máy tính thì bạn có thể nhấn tổ phím đó
là catalo
và bạn tin đến Facebook mà bạn thân Mở
ví dụ số 4 này
các thao tác thường dùng trong Word và
như vậy Vừa rồi mình đã chia sẻ xong các
thao tác
đóng
mà vào facebook
Tiếp theo mình sẽ sang nhóm thao tác thứ
hai đó là thao tác bố đen hay còn gọi là
chọn văn bản
ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ gọi nhanh một vài
nội dung
[âm nhạc]
Ví dụ như thế này mà mình biết một đoạn
nữa vào đây
khi bôi đen một loại nào đó khi bạn chỉ
cần đưa chuột vào cái điểm đầu cần mô
đen ví dụ bây giờ mình Bôi đen Cái dòng
chữ là đỗ vào Nam blog thì mạnh đưa
chuột vào điểm đầu cần mô đen sau đó
click và giữ chuột trái di chuyển đến
điểm cuối đó là điều này như vậy là bạn
đã bôi đen xong
trong trường hợp bạn muốn Bôi đen nhiều
nội dung hơn thì bạn có thể thực hiện
tương tự ví dụ mình Bôi đen cả một cái
câu này
ngoài ra mình có một cách khác để bạn
mua đen nhanh hơn ví dụ bây giờ mình
muốn mua đem toàn bộ cái đoạn này thì
bạn chỉ cần đưa chuột vào cái điểm đầu
của đoạn cần mô đen
sau đó bạn Nhấn và giữ phím ship
Kích và điểm cuối của các bạn cần mô đen
như vậy bạn đã bôi đen một đoạn có độ
giác bất kỳ theo ý muốn
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang nhóm thao tác thứ
ba đó là cá Vì sao chép cắt dán hoặc xóa
văn bản
ví dụ bây giờ mình muốn sao chép đoạn
văn bản này và dán xuống cái đoạn cuối
cùng thì đầu tiên bạn chỉ cần bôi đen
cái phần nội dung cần sao chép
sau đó bạn có thể biến to phím là
control C trên bàn phím
Hoặc bạn có thể tới chân phải
chạm copy Tuy nhiên bạn nên dùng phím
tắt cho nhanh
để sao chép bạn nhấn tổ hợp phím Control
C
sau khi đã sao chép xong bạn đưa con trỏ
chuột vào vị trí cần dán Ví dụ mình muốn
dán vào vị trí này
và bạn nhấn cho phím Control V để dán
văn bản vừa sao chép
như vậy mình đã thực hiện xong thao tác
sao chép và dán vàng cho sẽ cắt toàn văn
bản nào đó ví dụ đoạn văn bản này thì
đầu tiên bạn vẫn bôi lên đó
sau đó bạn nhấn tổ hợp phím can thận ích
và bạn có thể dán vào bất kỳ vị trí nào
Ví dụ như vị trí trên đầu tiên thời hạn
thì bạn cần đưa con trỏ chuột vào đúng
cái vị trí mà bạn cần dán sau đó bạn
nghiến conton V để dán văn bản mà bạn
vừa cắt tương tự để xóa một đoạn văn bản
nào đón thì bạn chỉ cần bôi đen văn bản
cần xóa
sau đó bạn chỉ cần nhấn phím delete trên
bàn phím để xóa văn bản
như vậy là xong
Tiếp theo mình sẽ sang nhóm thao tác thứ
tư đó là nhóm thao tác radio và undo hay
nói cách khác đó là khôi phục thao tác
vừa thực hiện hiện lại các thao tác mà
bạn đã lưu ý
cho
[âm nhạc]
ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ copy cái dòng đỗ
vào Nam vào lúc này nên phía trên này
mình copy được nghe giọng đi
bây giờ để khôi phục thao tác Bạn vừa
hiện có nghĩa là cứ thắc mình vừa dán
Cái dòng chữ đâu vào năm mà lúc đầu tiên
này thì bạn chỉ cần nhấn tổ hợp phím
Control Z
như vậy dòng chữ thứ hai của mình đã
không còn
và đẩy khôi phục lại cho tóc rồi bạn
nhấn cháu phím Control y như vậy dòng
chữ đôi 35 ốc lại hiện ra
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang nhóm thao tác thứ
các thao tác định dạng văn bản
ví dụ trong đoạn văn bản này ạ Bây giờ
mình sẽ định dạng để cho cái chữ căn đều
sang hai bên thì đầu tiên bạn cần phải
modem văn bản cần đình ra
sau đó trong tab home
mạnh Click vào cái icon đó là thân đều
sang hai bên Hoặc bạn có thể nhấn tàu
phím là controls
nếu bạn muốn căn sang phải bạn Click vào
icon camera phải
hoặc ăn trái hoặc căn giữa và bây giờ
mình sẽ căn 2 bên
Nếu bạn muốn thay đổi kiểu chữ thì trong
tôi bác Phong này vạn chọn 10 chữ phù
hợp Ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ chọn kiểu phông
chữ
ví dụ kiểu phông chữ này đi
đã tử cung chứ Mẫu giáo đi như thế này
đi
trong trường hợp bạn muốn tăng kích
thước của chữ thi ở trong cái phần cưa
chữ này tôi là không sai Bạn phải chọn
cơ chế phuộc ở kênh 14
Hoặc bạn có thể kích vào cái chữ an toàn
này để tăng kích thước chứ
Hai có thích và chữa nhỏ này để giảm
kích cho chứ
nếu bạn muốn viết chữ in đậm bạn dịch
vào cái chữ B hoặc nhấn tổ hợp phím game
Zombie
Nếu bạn muốn viết chữ in nghiêng bạn
thích vào cái chữ này hoặc nhấn tổ hợp
phím Control đi ngắn
Nếu bạn muốn viết chữ gạch chân thì bạn
kích vào cái chữ này Hoặc bạn có thể
nhấn tàu phím là Kangaroo Ví dụ ở đây
mình sẽ này như thế này
như vậy Vừa rồi mình vừa thực hiện nhanh
một số thao tác căn chỉnh văn bản
tiếp theo mình sẽ chuyển sang teves 6 đó
là trên ảnh Word
gian hàng nó vuốt là một cái công việc
khá thường gặp khi soạn thảo văn bản ra
để trên ảnh thì các anh như sau đầu tiên
bạn chọn vị trí Cần chèn thì bạn cần đưa
dấu ngay chuột vào đúng với chính cần
trên ảnh
sau đó bạn vào Insert trên menu
chọn picture
Ford Transit device
đối với một số cái phiên bản Word cũ thì
bạn chỉ cần chọn picture là được tuy
nhiên lên mình đang dùng bút 2021 do lại
bạn cần trọng giữ device để tìm đến hình
ảnh trong máy tính
và mạng tìm đến thư mục chứa ảnh
ví dụ thư mục này
sau đó bạn chụp ảnh cơn sen và Click vào
Insert
như vậy ảnh đã được chèn vào Facebook ở
các video tiếp theo đâu bảo nằm với Đức
sẽ chia sẻ chi tiết hơn về các thao tác
trên ảnh cũng như là một số thiết lập
cho ảnh khi chèn vào văn bản bây giờ giả
sử của mình sẽ chỉnh cho cái hình ảnh
nhỏ a
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang một nhóm thao tác
nữa nó thật trên bảng word
Ví dụ mình sẽ chèn vào vị trí này
thì đầu tiên bạn vẫn đưa cái dấu nháy
chuột vào vị trí Cần xem
sau đó bạn vào Insert trên menu
chọn thấy bồ
hoa văn vẽ đúng số dòng cũng như số cột
bạn cần chèn ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ chèm
4 cụt 3 dòng như thế này
và mình có thể nhập cái thông tin vào
đây
để chuyển nhanh giữa các cô thì bạn có
thể nhấn phím pháp
và để điều chỉnh kích thước của các cô
này cũng như các dòng thì bạn đưa con
chuột vào
những đường kẻ này
khi con ruột chuyển sang hình mũi tên
như bạn nhìn thấy trên màn hình thì bạn
kéo để điều chỉnh kích thước
ví dụ trong trường hợp bạn có 3 dòng
nhưng bạn muốn thêm dữ liệu khác thì bạn
chỉ cần đưa chuột vào cái ô cuối cùng và
bạn hiến pháp thì nó sẽ tự sinh ra một
dòng mới
và trong quá trình soạn thảo văn bản bạn
nhớ nhấn cho phím Control s thường xuyên
để lưu lại các thao tác mà bạn đã tự
nhiên
và như vậy Vừa rồi đâu bạn nam và đức đã
chia sẻ nhanh với bạn một số thao tác cơ
bản thường dùng trong Word
ở các video tiếp theo Đỗ Bảo Nam vào lúc
sẽ đi vào một số cái nội dung chuyên đề
chi tiết để các bạn hiểu rõ hơn sâu hơn
và nếu bạn thấy câu này của mình hay và
hữu ích và đáng ngờ và ngay Và chia sẻ
quyết hôn để ủng hộ Đỗ Bảo Nam và Đốc ở
Đông thai Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh đỗ
vào Nam lúc thì bạn hãy nhấp vào nút
đăng ký
A và chọn từ tượng hình chuông chọn tất
cả để đăng ký cũng như nhận thêm các Đâu
Huy khác Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video
tiếp theo